the year is almost over so we're
counting down some of our favorite new
shows that came out this year right now
on couch tomatoes what's up friends
omnes Perez and aside from presidents
and Star Wars the holidays are also
about staying home and watching TV so we
factored in tomato meter and audience
scores nominations and awards and what's
trending online to bring you this list
of some of our favorite new shows of
2019 in no particular order you are
dealing with something that has never
occurred on this planet first up is
HBO's Chernobyl Chernobyl is a hit
miniseries that follows the aftermath of
the catastrophic explosion at the
Chernobyl plant in Ukraine that happened
back in 1986 Chernobyl was the show that
everyone was talking about and watching
after Game of Thrones ended and was
heavily praised for its depiction of the
Soviet Union and the great lengths it
went through to recreate the chaos and
terror of the man-made disaster the
costumes set designs and props gave an
nearly realistic feel to the collapsing
Empire not to mention standout
performances by Jared Harris Emily
Watson and Selin skarsgård I anticipated
this there are only five episodes
clocking in and around an hour each and
with a certified fresh' score of 96% on
the tomato meter 19 Emmy nominations
including ten wins
and four Golden Globe nominee visit the
stats and if you're into watching
miniseries about people dying next up on
our list is Netflix is Russian doll
[ __ ] Christ our Russian doll follows
Nadia played by a natasha Lyonne who
keeps dying and returning to a party
that's being thrown in her honor only
there were an easier way to ditch party
am i right it's hard to fully describe
without giving away major spoilers but
season one follows our journey through
the most horrific and life-altering
night of her life and Leone also serves
as co-creator alongside Amy Poehler and
Lesley headland Russian dolls first
season is 97% certified fresh' on the
tomato meter and landed the show 13 Emmy
nominations three of which they won an
Leone is up for Best Actress in a
television series at the Golden Globes
at eight episodes long 30 minutes each
this is the show you can ditch that
party for just be mindful of the stairs
on the way out birthday baby what was
they just doing what what do you mean
and while you're on Netflix you might
want to check out the series
unbelievable the show tells the shocking
true story of Murray a rape survivor who
gets charged with false reporting after
the first detectives on her case accuse
her of lying about the rape two
detectives in separate precincts
investigating oddly similar attacks find
a link that may finally validate her
this one series pulls from a few
different sources including T Christian
Miller and Ken Armstrong's Pulitzer
winning article from Pro Publica an
unbelievable story of rape and the
American Life podcast episode anatomy of
doubt the 97% certified fresh' season is
up for four Golden Globes believe it or
not and in one of the most unbelievable
turn of events of the decade this next
show gave us the one gift we just didn't
know we needed baby Yoda the Mandalorian
on Disney Plus is set five years after
the events of Return of the Jedi and the
fall of the Galactic Empire and is the
first ever live-action Star Wars TV show
season 1 is 93% certified fresh and
follows a lone bounty hunter known as
the Mandalorian and if you haven't been
a lifelong Star Wars fan what are you
doing just kidding the force is on your
side with this one cuz creator Jon
Favreau and Dave Filoni both say that
with the new set of characters anyone's
able to jump in and appreciate the show
and the fact that baby Oda has made
social media fun again will never look
at our moms the same way on Christmas
ever again and from Star Wars to
superheroes this next show takes place
in a world where superheroes are super
real and super [ __ ] up they're just
like us it's Amazon's the boys developed
by Seth Rogen and Evan Goldberg the 84
percent certified fresh' series is
packed with tons of violent action dark
comedic themes Jesus Lee gives the worst
pep talks Unidos and breathes new life
into the superhero genre in just eight
episodes right it's wild and weird and
the characters all seem very grounded
and relatable except for that whole
having powers thing add in a spectacular
cast and storylines and it's no surprise
to hear fans are stoked about the
recently announced season 2 coming in
2020 so it's time to hop on that
bandwagon and speaking of bandwagons the
reason you probably saw everyone
we're glitter on their faces Halloween
was thanks to HBO's hit teen drama
euphoria the show follows the life of
Roo Bennett played by zendaya a 17 year
old drug addict fresh out of rehab with
no real plans to stay sober it's a raw
and unfiltered take into modern-day
adolescence and dives deep into sex
drugs violence addiction and depression
the controversial show was heavily
criticized for going too far and being
too graphic for their target audience
the second episode had a record 30
penises on screen but what really had
everyone talking is India's performance
her portrayal of a manipulative teen
addict is played with so much heart and
vulnerability that it actually makes you
feel bad for her character and Angus
cloud also received a ton of praise for
his breakout role as Fez a high school
dropout drug dealer I'm to be having
this conversation right now
season one of euphoria is certified
fresh' with an 83 percent on the tomato
meter and audiences seem to agree giving
it an audience score of 83% another show
you should probably add to your watch
list is HBO's Watchmen the Internet's
been buzzing about Watchmen since it was
first announced in 2018 and the series
has lived up to the hype week after
jaw-dropping week and the second to last
episode is one of the best hours of TV
of the year created by Damon Lindelof
who gave us lost and leftovers Watchmen
is set in present-day three decades
after the release of the graphic novel
by Alan Moore which is set in the 1980s
and the show takes place in a dystopian
society where masked vigilantes take on
white supremacist in Tulsa Oklahoma the
series stars Regina king who plays
Angela a bar a bakery owner who is also
a masked vigilante called sister Knight
and the ultimate badass she makes me
want to rock a rosary season 1 is
certified fresh with a 97% on the tomato
meter and is bold thrilling and
uncomfortably relevant and when it comes
to uncomfortability Netflix's sex
education has got it down to an art form
I've noticed still pretending to
masturbate and I was wondering if he
wanted to talk about sex education is a
comedy about a teenager named Otis
played by Asa Butterfield who's battling
his hormones and a helicopter mom who
also happens to be a sex therapist
played by Gillian Anderson the 8 episode
series follows English teens who decide
to open an underground sex therapy
clinic to answer the biggest
misconceptions we have about
sex the show is openly graphic in a way
that will probably mortify you as much
as it will your parents but the way you
tell stories about the anxieties of sex
is cleverly relatable no matter how old
you are this show is perfect for fans of
big mouths or the cult classic freaks
and geeks and sex education is coming
back for a season two in 2020 the next
show on our list is ava duvernay for
part Netflix miniseries when they see us
the show was about the Central Park five
a group of five teenagers from Harlem
who were wrongfully convicted of a crime
in Central Park in 1990 the Lewis Life
is one other way they haven't do us the
series follows the individual journeys
that these teens went through as they
were coerced into giving false
confessions serve time for a crime they
did not commit and their exoneration in
2002 Terrell Jerome gives a most
powerful performance in a series as
Corey wise which he plays the young and
old version of by the way which landed
him his first Emmy Award the limited
series was nominated for 16 Emmy Awards
earlier this year and is certified
fresh' with a 96 percent on the tomato
meter and last but not least is servant
streaming on Apple TV Plus season one is
currently certified fresh' at 84 percent
on the tomato meter and follows a couple
who pretends their son Jericho is still
alive after he dies with the use of a
reborn doll
move over Annabelle she's gone you can
put a dog down dorothy suffered a full
psychotic break and the doll is the only
thing that releases her from her
catatonic state the show is M night
Shyamalan production at its finest with
ominous shots of staircases and hallways
big twists and an m9 cameo the main
location is even on a Philadelphia
Street that resembles the one from the
famous car scene in The Sixth Sense a
second season has already been announced
so maybe catch up on this one after the
baby's asleep
alright friends that's our list of our
favorite new shows to come out in 2019
what was your favorite new show that
came out this year and are there any
shows that you think we missed it should
be added to this list let us know all
your thoughts in the comment section and
don't forget to hit that subscribe
button and notification valve so you
don't miss any future couch tomato
episodes I'm now spreads and happy
holiday vision
[Music]